case from the daily wire it says dorne
becker children's hospital in portland
which bills itself as oregon's
top-ranked
uh children's hospital boasts a gender
clinic which offers advice for the safe
tucking of a boy's genitals
out of the way quote unquote that can
make quote the general area look
smoother and flatter as well as a
referral to a quote sex positive shop in
portland they sell gender affirming
clothe items as well as sex toys videos
and more
so there's a children's hospital
referring children to a sex shop
while also giving them tips on tucking
what's that all about well the resource
on safe tucking from the gender clinic
states quote safe tucking what is
tucking tucking is moving the penis
testicles are both out of the way this
makes the genital area look smoother and
flatter tucking can reduce any concerns
you have about your body how your
clothes fit and how safe you feel in
public people of all genders can tuck
there are several different methods of
tucking the information below helps you
tuck in ways that are safe for your body
according to the hospital's website it
works in cooperation with the
oregon health and science university
transgender health program the ohsu logo
is also emblazoned on the safe tucking
handout
the handout cautions quote a note on the
words we use
this information uses the words penis
scrotum and testicles we know you may
not use those terms or identify with
them we use them here to refer to body
parts that people with tucking needs
have
people with tucking needs
while understanding those words are not
for everyone
the resource advises it is best to talk
for the first time when you're planning
to be at home this keeps you from
stressing about having to get get it
right the first time it's also easier to
learn what your body needs to be
comfortable when you tuck choose a
method that feels comfortable for to you
and i just can't even keep reading this
absolutely revolting and this is a
children's hospital
this is
you hear me talk about this issue all
the time because
you know that i believe
that um gender ideology and especially
its effects on kids this is
probably the number one issue we face as
a society right now
um
but even as much as i talk about it
if you listen to the show
you still probably
don't quite comprehend
just how bad this is
how widespread this madness is
um
how ubiquitous how ingrained it has
become
i don't think anyone even i can't fully
comprehend it
because i'm i'm living through it
and it's the kind of thing that you
can't fully understand it's like it's a
historical you know anytime you're
living through a historical period or
some sort of historical event
you you the people who are in it can't
they don't have the view of it that you
have when you're
later when you can look back
um
and so even for me it's it's it's
impossible to fully comprehend
what we are doing
to ourselves and especially to our kids
i mean what this this generation
that we're raising right now what is
what's this generation going to look
like
in 30 years
how many of them are still going to be
here
because a huge portion let's say one
thing we're going to see
and we're already starting to see now
and it's only going to get worse
mass suicide epidemic
among these kids
who who we have taken
and when i say we i mean society
has has taken and
uh
forced an identity crisis onto them
and completely from the youngest ages
completely
morphed and deformed their their concept
of themselves
and put them on a path towards
destroying and rejecting their own
bodies
to a point where eventually they're
going to look back and so much damage
has been done that can't be undone and
they're going to say who am i what am i
what have what have i done what have you
all as the adults allowed me to do what
have you done to me
[Music]